nintendo has detailed its financial
results for the nine-month period
spanning april to december 2015
reporting a decrease in sales compared
to the same period in 2014 put an
increase in operating profit I'm Kate
and this is your gamespot news update
nintendo reported 425 billion yen or 3.5
billion dollars in sales of the period
which represents a 3.9 percent decrease
compared to the same nine months in 2014
this is the fifth year in a row when in
tendo's sales have declined operating
profit however was reported as forty two
point four billion yen or 352 million
dollars which is an increase of
thirty-four percent for the same period
in 2014 this was partly due to
cost-cutting measures as well as more
profitable sources of income such as
legacy digital titles Nintendo also sold
3.6 million we use systems last year
bringing lifetime global sales of the
console to 12 million units but game
sales on the console only at 79 million
less than a tenth of the wii's total
software sales so are you concerned
about Nintendo or will they be just fine
let me know in the comments or come and
find me on Twitter I'm at how not to
draw thanks for watching and for all
your gaming and entertainment news keep
it gamespot
you